If you press the Honda remote button,
the right light stay on for a while, but
it doesn't work. Neither shut nor open
the door. You are at the right place. I
will show you a few tricks to fix it.
First, to replace Honda CRV, the key
batteries. The batteries you need is a
CR1620. The tools you need Philip
screwdrivers and a flat screwdriver. You
unscrew it.
Use the flat screwdriver gently pry
open and then use the flat screwdriver
to pry out
battery. Install the new battery.
Put it in. If it doesn't work after you
replace battery, you need to clean it.
So, I need to take off
this, take off the rubber
boot, and then I used air duster to blow
the duster away.
[Music]
And then I used the contact cleaner to
clean the three buttons related circuit.
I leave the links in the description
below if you need a contact cleaner or
air
duster. I reassembled the key for
test. After you replace battery and
clean the key, if it work,
congratulation. If you're not, you need
to reprogram your key. Enter the
vehicle, lock all the doors, and turn
the key to the two position or on
position. And then press and hold lock
or unlock key for a few
seconds and then press another key and
hold and then press another key
again. You can also uh use the so-called
formal way. You turn the key to the on
position. Press and hold one second and
then turn to the off position. Repeat
this another two times and then you turn
to the on position. Press unlock key and
wait for the door to unlock. Test inside
the car to see the signal pairing. And
then test outside of a
car. Lock it. It's locked. Press
unlock. And then you can open the door.
Double click the
lock. That's a sound of a success.